بعد اول لقاء مع عبد الله باتيلي رئيسي
بعثه الامم المتحده للدعم في ليبيا اعلن
ناصر بوريطه وزير الخارجيه المغربي ان
الامم المتحده هي التي يمكنها حصريا ايجاد
حل في ليبيا بعيدا عن التدخلات الاجنبيه
المغرب
[موسيقى]
المتحده في ليبيا من الرباط دعوه الى
الليبيين من اجل الحوار
اسواقف نفسك
من مصلحه الليبيين الليبيون يعبرون عن هذا
بطريقه قويه ويريدون مؤسسات مستقره وذات
شرعيه تفتح الطريق امام الازدهار في بلدهم
على البقاء دائما على مسافه واحده من
الاطراف فيما ترى بعثه الامم المتحده
للدعم في ليبيا ان الشرعيه في هذا البلد
لا يمكن حلها الا عبر انتخابات رئاسيه
وبرلمانيه بعثته الامم المتحده للدعم في
ليبيا مع رئيسها الجديد تعتبر المغرب احد
الشركاء الدوليين في الملف الليبيه فيما
رباطته ترى بعثه الامم المتحده للدعم في
ليبيا مظله لما سارين اثنين يحتضنهما
المغرب حول الاز الليبيه مسارس خيرات
ومصار بوزنيقه عادل الزبير العربيه الرباط